[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast we're running two
minutes late because we couldn't stop
Gavin we're a bunch of Gavin gals it's
not a good morning I feel so stressed I
feel heavy like there's so much going on
there's so much going on and I feel
stressed like not because of anything
going on in my own life though I'm
taking it on as if it is but because of
what went down in bachelor in paradise
last night and with the launch of our
going to show the structure it has given
us so much time to talk about it we are
going to record an episode right after
this the first episode of the snaps are
will be up today but we'd be absolutely
we're miss devastated and heartbroken if
we didn't talk about what went out on
Instagram last night here we won't take
up all your time because we know not
everyone watches the snatchler but we
will matter it's the same thing it's
naturally will be before overall in the
podcast story we are she snatched his
people spots we will be discussing in
depth everything that happened on
bachelor in paradise
all the drama of Blake and Bella Coola
and Caitlyn obviously but also there's a
lot of other interesting things going on
that I really would have prefered they
spend their time talking about last
night so we will be diving deep into how
annoying Emily says oh my god
why can't be beyond if I love she's
literally the most perfect precious gem
of a woman with her body sparkles and
her perfect face makeup without wearing
any mix she's Benjamin buttoning no she
looks so good there's so much to talk
about and we will go into all the little
details but at some point today we will
be making it a story Blake and Caitlyn
just because how could we not how could
be not honestly I haven't stopped
thinking about it like I've just been
going over in my head like what's going
on
I believe that my opinion is a populist
popular maybe controversial ooh but I
feel as though it needs to be said and I
don't know if I can wait any longer
so no wait we can wait longer we're not
gonna jump right in it's 10:35 it's just
so top of mind for me I truly can't
think about anything else to ask if you
notice anything different about me
um like I do I do I'm looking I'm
wearing pants because I've officially
decided I'm no longer gonna subject
myself to summer treachery of Siberian
and chub-rub baring I am officially
taking my power back it is autumn in my
mind and I'm where
pants okay good luck with that and so
are you and long sleeves I'm wearing I
mean I'm wearing my businesswomen
special because we have hard-hitting
journalism to report on today and that's
just my [ __ ] cross to bear so she let
you go investigate what that was thank
you so much we're also going to do dear
toasters today which is our weekly
advice Eggman you can email to your
toasters at gmail.com if you have any
cool what's the word quandary quadtrees
about your love life to dating life your
work life let us know he does habituate
toasters at gmail.com we always keep it
anonymous don't you worry yeah that'll
be fun right now I'm gonna do deer
twisters for Kaitlyn justice for Kaitlyn
my friends okay to everything that
you're gonna say I'm gonna make it about
Kaitlyn Blake because it's all I can
think about
did you watch your house of Orange
County yes it was it was okay honestly I
thought it was great I love what's her
name Bronwyn Bronwyn is a horseman
honestly her name is a combination of
Melaka Leia and horseman
[Laughter]
you know what when I first met her I was
like oh she's so cute she has seven kids
she must live in a palace but she had
like a very regular house nothing like
anyone to judge other people's houses
but in the housewives realm like you
have to judge and I just have to say
like the people the houses in a Orange
County have always been quite diverse
yeah but I just expected a little bit
more from Bronwyn I happened to be
looking down at my phone when they
showed her house so I knew it and I
don't know if anyone else has YouTube TV
and it updated for you but now it's like
really touch on sensitive so if you want
to go over wine like you better be damn
sure that's what you want to do because
you're about to watch the whole episode
over again I thought you know what
they'll show me Bronwyn's house at
another time that's so funny okay I
could so she might be living in a
mansion on a hill so or not I would say
it's like bigger than Tamra's but not
not as like elevated and it's lesser
than like Emily and Vicki's I consider
Emily and Vicki to have the nicest
houses okay do you would you agree uh
it's just I don't know it's like when
you see someone who's hot but you know
them too well so they're like no not
anymore
that's how I feel about each of their
house cameras new house is mad cute
definitely step up I love that she's in
it she appreciates a country club more
than us total running around her kitchen
with her like itinerary from her country
club that is so something we would do a
hundred percent it is the season of
Shannon's
looking like a [ __ ] snack and a
piece of [ __ ] snatchler today yes and
I'm obsessed with her friendship with
Kelly Dodd like it is just I'm obsessed
with Kelly Dodd me too and you know I
recently started following a lot of like
housewife not fan accounts but just like
commentators who have like a lot of
funny things to say about housewives and
I guess a lot of them are like really up
in arms that Vicki is not a part of the
season and they were just like tweeting
negative things and just like boycotting
the season and then they were just like
coming for Kelly because they stand
Vicki and they don't want Kelly to be on
the show and they were saying such mean
things about her boyfriend but I think
he's like such a cutie they sound like
LBP sands and - Vicki started out the
season like with the potential to be a
housewife she's invited to the first
party blah blah blah the weight however
like whatever she did this season was
meant in her friend of housewives that I
said enough so it was on her it didn't
we didn't start the season her not being
a housewife like she was given this yeah
because like it was only announced at
the end that she was friend of housewife
she was filming with them she is invited
to this party like it's over going on a
trip and I think she's heard so far
everything's going like Vicki is a
housewife
yeah but they just didn't now show her
like package for this heat like the
beginning of this year because she
turned out not to be
he's my wifey oh yeah yeah well I am I
like Kylie John's boyfriend I think he's
such a PGM like he's advised her jewelry
he's the plastic surgeon this is like
the perfect relationship totally classic
surgeon and a housewife Lisa Hochstein I
just kind of get that snatchler I just
found myself the whole episode being
like so many things were just
Kelly Kelly and Shannon delicious Kelly
and her new boyfriend
Tamra's new house Shannon's new body
please so many things that were worthy I
just don't know if I would ever decide
Real Housewives of Orange County is and
if we're recapping TV we need to be
talking about Caitlyn Blake so well is
there anything else you want to recap
before we jump into all the drums no I'm
ready let me jump
I'm not leaving why are you stalling I
don't know I just like cuz honestly like
I have a paid about the whole situation
I don't know I mean I feel like I've
mentioned myself on this show I was like
the person with no opinion because I
just like firmly stand in the middle of
like every single debate but I'm firmly
standing in the middle of this debate
and I know it's popular to be on Blake
side now since like the text messaging
yes I think for the purposes of this
show
good for where you're at because we need
a little balance because I'm going to
take Katelyn side here but everyone is
on Blake side so we need someone to
speak for those people cool I'm gonna
tell you my Blake side though okay well
let's get right into it without further
ado these are the past five stories that
you absolutely need to know they are
pertinent to the situation that you know
them before you take a bite out of your
morning toes
but before we do you have to be
absolutely we're miss heartbroken and
devastated if I didn't let you know that
today's episode is brought to you by
care of vitamins get back into a healthy
routine with summer approaching make
health and wellness a priority again
carob makes it easy to upgrade your
health routine give yourself support
this season with a boost of energy
whether you're looking for better energy
better sleep to maintain stress or
something else to help you feel your
healthiest carob is a website where you
take a personalized online quiz which we
absolutely love asking you what your
health needs are like trying to curate
the perfect vitamin package for you and
then every month they will send you a
stack of vitamins in prepackaged little
pouches that are so cute you can just
throw in your purse perfect for travel I
have a show ganda I have milk thistle
just to like make my Judy's a little bit
you know smoother it's been really
premium and it's easy as hell because
those little pill boxes are not cute and
then like opening all the bottles some
of them have to be in the fridge it's
not a premium experience teen vitamins
but care enough makes it super premium
they really do and my bones are stronger
because of it they make sure what you're
putting into your body comes from the
best sources backed by honest guidance
and transparency all available to you on
their website carob now offers protein
powders available in individual packets
for on-the-go and tubs all personalized
to your fitness goals and dietary
preferences swanky for $25 off your
first care of order go to take care of
comm and enter code toast TOA st that's
take care of comm and 25% off using code
toast TOA st vegan and vegetarian
supplement options are available to
match your dietary needs and to ensure
you're getting the nutrients you need
for those specific diets look at them
just being like you know thinking about
everyone yeah love care of if you
haven't checked it out do so now it is
last night episode 2 bachelor in
paradise aired we continued on this
Blake drama
he slept with two girls at stagecoach
Christina comes in takes him on a date
turns out she's his worst nightmare and
can I just talk about something for a
minute like when I first found out that
she was taking him on the date I'm like
damn I have no respect for this girl
then she's like
I'm gonna plot it I'm like okay whatever
but like really that's what you go to
Paradise for to have a conversation you
could have had at the beach like why
don't you use an experience to move past
and evolve and be mature but no you're
gonna like stay in your in your past and
waste this great opportunity could have
been a great day with someone yeah and
it was a waste of a date but you know it
was good to watch Blake be put in his
place yes about the sleeping with two
girls thing which I agree with him
they're single and it's it's not his
best looking moment but like he didn't
cheat on anyone both girls wanted to
hook up with him whatever and he got
just being a [ __ ] but when we got the
iconic line from Christina did she
change her sheets right which honestly
great question because definitely not
definitely not he was definitely staying
in a rental like they give you extra
sheets like they change him at the end
of the weekend that's disgusting
but I just have to say as much as that
conversation was like necessary like
they were talking in circles they were
not making any sense like Christina had
so many things she could be upset about
and she like wasn't even she was making
no sense like the whole conversation was
just like had so much potential to like
really put him in his place but like it
didn't all the tables let him know that
like she was still mad and that she knew
right and he already like before she
didn't said anything is like defeated
his name has been smeared he's so upset
like he's only thinking about like how
he's gonna look and not how he's
affected other people which I just
thought was like a shitty way to handle
a thousand percent and he said it more
than one time in his confessionals in
the conversations just being like oh my
god like being obsessed with how he was
gonna be perceived and when you're on a
TV show I guess that's definitely
something you have to keep in mind but
for that to be literally the only thing
you care about is so shady so shady then
he comes back in Kalin's fine after it
crying in the corner for two days she's
finally ready to talk to him about how
upset she is and anyway she was crying
in the corner because she was like
obviously like still upset about what
happened but I think what made it so
much worse is that like she got there
and they didn't talk like it's obvious
that they have some sort of like
deep-rooted history and he was like
ignoring her yeah so I think everyone's
focusing on the fact that they think
that they hooked up at stagecoach with
which Kaelin really wanted according to
these text messages and then he like hit
it and quit it and wanted to like lie
about it or something but there's more
to the story in these screenshots I
think are so unfair because one it's
five screenshots select few screenshots
out of months long of communication for
relationship they were in I mean this is
a problem now with gotcha
no one knows how to define a
relationship and like no one wants to
call anyone their girlfriend but like
when you're talking to someone every day
when you're hanging out with them like
when you can when you're in town and
you're hooking up in your [ __ ] like
maybe you're not boyfriend and
girlfriend but you are in some sort of a
relationship right and what those text
messages didn't provide was any context
because he's really trying to make it
seem like this was like a one-time thing
or like they didn't really have any sort
of relationship when we know for a fact
that like there were months and months
of hanging out together being secretive
like in a relationship communicating
like everyday and from what we know it's
starting to make sense because they I
guess they were hanging out in dating
while her season while Colton season was
airing so they don t I it was a big
secret because you can't be dating
anyone when you're a contestant on The
Bachelor in your show and your [ __ ] is
live especially not someone else in
bachelor nation and Kaylin I think was
definitely a contender for being the
Bachelorette so like they really had to
keep their relationship on the DL but
what no one's talking about and what
these text messages fail to include is
that there was a full-fledged
relationship going on for a very long
time and so by the time we get to
stagecoach he's her ex and she's drunk
texting her ex and like first of all
such an invasion of privacy like I'm
firmly in the middle but I just think
like releasing someone's text messages
when they're drunk when you were in a
relationship with them is the biggest
violation of privacy like I would
literally die if anyone saw my messages
to bed when I was like wasted like
either we're fighting or I'm being
inappropriate like I just I would die
that were like - in accent if you're
someone who's like judging her for these
text messages like I just really want to
see your drunk text so what I can see
how perfect you are so first of all him
including that sex part was so
inappropriate and like I would get it
you had sex and she was into it like no
one's asking you if she was like
consenting to the rights but what the
text messages I did find to be
particularly interesting that really
made me and I'd like Cailin and like I
actually feel bad for it I can imagine
like all these people doubting her like
really triggering for her based on what
she went through when she was in college
so I really feel for and I want to be on
her side but what these text messages
and I don't even think he realized when
he posted this one particular part was
like she came to paradise like really
upset over the fact that he made her
keep it a secret
when these text messages proved that
they both wanted to keep it a secret
which is not bad but she shouldn't have
like put her fork in the sand or
whatever the phrases on the fact that
she was most upset that he made her feel
like a dirty secret when they both were
cool to make it feel like a secret yeah
but he if they wanted it to be a secret
he should have gone to paradise and at
least like said hi to her and
acknowledge her and treated her like a
human being you're not they were in a
relationship and I think that's what
hurt the most and that's why she's like
sitting there sobbing because he/she
comes to paradise her ex is there he's
the king of paradise and she is the
sorry people and she just can't stop
crying and like yeah I don't think she's
an actress and if like she is she's a
terrible one and her store like
everything is just messy and I think if
she were more calculated it wouldn't be
this messy and I think taking five
screenshots and yet by the by the end of
the screenshots where she was down for
the lie we don't know how much coercing
in phone calls and all that happened
between them before that that made her
okay to go and lie about it like it's
just this is so [ __ ] messy messy so
lame of him to do that because honestly
by the time you put these messages on
Instagram I was so over this storyline
like cool you [ __ ] two girls at
stagecoach but it's Lee he's not
stagecoach and I don't know how he had
the [ __ ] time we weren't with him the
whole time like we kept running into him
that we eventually just like became a
part of each other's trips like the fact
that he had times like be so messy and
[ __ ] two different girls is shocking
because we were literally with him the
entire night yeah we entire weekend yeah
so that's maybe why I just feel like
some type of way about this because now
that it's like about us but we are kind
of adjacent to the situation and because
we were there and we were definitely
hanging out with both of these parties
and he came on the show and like he is
such a smooth talker what all the girls
are saying I'm paradise and when what he
came here like I think everyone in the
room like had a crush on him yeah but I
think after statehood like there is a
little wheeling and dealing yeah and you
know what like I don't necessarily think
you're a bad person if you're like
[ __ ] different girls like maybe you
know he wasn't drowning in [ __ ] before
the bachelor like now he is and he want
to take advantage of that and like Dean
is a fuck-boy but like he cause he likes
to [ __ ] a lot of girls that doesn't make
you a bad person yeah and I firmly and
he was just like getting he was
definitely in his own head when all this
stuff was happening on paradise and like
he doesn't realize like the world was
talking about Luke pee and Jed five
minutes ago and like literally if they
couldn't pick him out of a lineup like I
don't care anymore like things change so
fast but for him he was like the world
is falling apart and like I need to do
this is so messy there's so many gaps
missing I feel like this is Tati
Westbrook and I feel as though our are
you gonna steal my call by the way I
thought it before you decide
I said it's me to feel my call but no I
thought it before you even said it like
you think you're so convinced when you
see this because it's like oh this has
to be true and the world is commenting
every single person from bachelor nation
girl's included be like tell your truth
you're so vulnerable
like that's what we thought with Tati
and then James comes in and I thought at
the time I'm like there is nothing James
could say that would make me believe him
and now you know I am James Charles tan
with my James Charles phone case like I
feel as though I don't know if Kalyan is
gonna respond but I feel as though she
might have some some serious receipts
I didn't mean to copy your analogy I
thought it as well I said it to Ben and
he was like what are you talking about
I'm like just get away yeah and I think
everyone on the bachelor franchise
especially in paradise
you know you never know who editing is
gonna make you look everyone goes
through it everyone comes off badly at
times but to go so low as to find
something that would make me a would
make you look good but make someone else
look so bad and like if I were her I
would never [ __ ] get drunk and text a
person that I liked ever again like how
like it like this these are private
messages like I shouldn't be reading
them the snatchler where do you stand so
last night when he released the text I
was like I'm staunchly on Team Kaitlyn
just because like just I didn't I
literally didn't care what they said
you're something that he did it there's
something so lowdown a dirty thing you
actually have to release some someone
short text like that and we need to talk
about a statement for a second cuz he
put the statement I'm in then ten
minutes later he released the text and I
have to say when I saw the statement I
did DM them because we have opened James
and I was like I really don't think you
should do it and he never answered so
and our team I was on Team Kalin and
like and obviously I'm really never on
the side that Twitter is on that night
in the morning that that's just my cross
to bear but so then I was thinking and
it's like okay the problem isn't that
they had sex at stagecoach yeah okay
honestly the thing is is that when
nobody on Kalin's side is like when
nobody's talking about because nobody
knows is that they were in a
relationship for months so everyone's
like it was a one-night thing in contest
nice in context like why is she getting
so mad like blah blah blah so that's
what you need to know they were in a
relationship she drunk texted her ex and
that's why she was so far word do you
think if she just liked this guy she
would be that far to be like no let's
just have sex like no they clearly had
sex before like brights and on go he
wouldn't say that to someone you've
never had sex with like she's not a
prostitute
aquiline is that like the way she
approached the whole thing on Paradise
but do you think that could be related
to editing maybe but we saw in those
texts I where a week before and he even
said on the show I'm sorry Christina
said on the show yesterday that Blake
told him a week before and she was like
well that's convenient and now we know
it's because him and Calum are trying to
figure out if they should tell people I
don't know just Christina like leaving
comments on his pictures like you're
very much a part of this too and like
you should be mad at Blake you're just
like the girl who like gets mad at the
girl your husband had an affair with and
like not your husband you know yeah the
worst kind of girl I asked yeah I hate
Christine she's the one who gets mad at
the girl like yeah and but there was a
special place in hell for girls like she
doesn't realize that Kailyn is a [ __ ]
Ally yeah yes so if she don't know each
other at the state make enemy of my
enemy is my friend and these two girls
could've and I don't think he needs to
be taken down or whatever but he just
needs to treat like the people that he's
[ __ ] a little better
no just have a little grace for the
girls you're penetrating I don't really
feel as though I'm asking that much I
don't think it's like they weren't in a
relationship does anyone have
confirmation
this is escaping you confirmation that
we know for a fact we know for a fact
like we're not super friendly with
Kailyn like we've met her twice but we
have mutual friends with her and we know
for a fact that they were in a
relationship and not yet us giving you
the T that no one else will and that's
what these text messages are so
problematic one cuz it's a [ __ ] up
thing to do but two because they lack
the most important context yes context
is these screenshots like from the
stagecoach sex it's like he sent her a
picture jiff or something and then like
cut it out like what was it no yeah it's
strategically scrolled you know so it's
like I I don't care about your
screenshots like also like Ken
Vanderpump like go away yeah yeah this
is John Sesa written all those and then
you know it brought me back to another
Beverly Hills comparison because this
takes people back to Kalin verse Hannah
and like now it's like Oh Kailyn really
was the villain so manipulative blah
blah blah but in all of that we never
found out what happened because nothing
happened there just two girls who should
have got nothing no but didn't get along
and I feel like that happens all the
time like I was comparing like Drita and
Teddy like I love them both but they
don't like each other and there's
literally nothing in common
but there's nothing wrong with either
one of them and I feel like Kailyn and
Hannah are just
so different it doesn't make one of them
the [ __ ] and one of them the sorry
person it's just like they they drink
each other's people yeah that's fine
I feel like we should cap it here I
think so - I think we've we've given our
opinions we'll we'll go in-depth more
all about the statement on the snatchler
and then all the other things cuz I have
just as many thoughts on Blake and
Kailyn as I do on [ __ ] Annalise okay
we will talk about on the snap char
later today subscribe the snatchler the
snatcher
it's sweeping the nation and she's
coming to snatch your lure it's
happening yeah she's comin an hour and
she's a snatchler in paradise and that's
like this scary that's the craziest by
the way I just have to say there's
nothing even remotely paradesio about
paradise like those beds the humidity
like oh no I think the ocean is
literally a green-screen
like they keep they're not like it
they'll get zapped like a dog they don't
write except someone Jim whatever
Jim someone jumped in like and it was so
inspiring just to prove that it was a
real ocean at the end of last episode I
literally like bursting I'm so ready for
this natural recap so everyone it'll be
up later today second story
switching gears FX is next American
crime story is about Bill Clinton's sex
scandal waiting for like the theme of
the new American Horror Story it's like
the most exciting time of my life
because you think like they couldn't do
any better than oj and actually firmly
believe that no matter how many american
horror stories we have like oj will
always be the best one and you think
they're like we're gonna do Jon Benet
like the most obvious ones but they
always come up with the most creative
like never in my mind did I think that
Monica Lewinsky the the Bill Clinton
thing would be American but they did it
I'm so here for it and Gianni Versace
was amazing was amazing um this is a
doozy also because like for a lot of us
who would be watching this like we were
so young when all this happened like I
don't really know that the intricacies
no me neither and I don't know I
actually when I mean oh it's like for
the OJ it's like the same era as OJ
where we we grew up with it but we
weren't watching the news no and when we
were on Access Hollywood I turned on my
TV I was in a hotel room on tour and
they were like your segments airing
tonight and I was like oh [ __ ] yes and I
put on ABC NBC and I guess like we got
canceled or something because we had to
we were actually on the next week but
instead they played this Monica Lewinsky
like hour-long special and it was wildly
interesting like so many of the
intricacies and there was this lady who
took things that Monica told her and
released to the press like so many drama
so much drama that I'm actually really
looking forward to this and also the
casting of Enoch they've seen this
Monica Lewinsky is probably the most
inspired casting choice of our
generation also what we didn't talk
about is Queen Latifah being cast as
Ursula in The Little Mermaid is that
confirmed she put it on her Instagram
loved it let me double check that it was
Ursula she's playing but loved it I
don't think it's Ursula cuz I thought
I'm Melissa McCarthy I'm looking it up
but I think you might be right but that
was just that was up yes she's ours Oh
in the Little Mermaid live oh great so
now we have to go through this again I
just [ __ ] Cassie think oh you're
gonna be Ariel in the Little Mermaid
lively show woman Moana oh the girl yeah
but I just have to say like justice for
Queen Latifah like everything she's in
truly turns to gold like chess right
that's maybe of all time a barbershop
literally the beauty chefs holiday last
holiday and when we hairspray of course
and when she sings like she can do no
wrong so hairspray live just enough
hairspray live little mermaid live just
got like just got so lucky yeah it's
gonna be a hit now a live program stands
a chance
yeah but sorry tell me more about
American Heart Association after winning
a Best Actress limited Primetime Emmy
for her turn as Marcia Clark will return
to the anthology as Linda Tripp I think
that's the woman that you're talking
about who Monica confided in
yeah and ended up at writing her was it
a betrayal or she spoke up about the in
justices I don't know we're gonna find
out we'll see Jackie we'll see what the
narrative they take is they could be
biased you could paint it either way
lemon is a betrayal or she was a hero
okay I have actually like I'm not even
I'm just asking a question I really
don't know I know not all I know is that
there were 16 the [ __ ] and like he
put a cigar I don't know and there was a
dress a blue dress hidden like it was
like [ __ ] gloves when the house was
white yes I believe into the shape of
not a circle but more like an oval
beneath unseen will a Monica Lewinsky
love it Annaleigh Ashford as Paula Jones
Lewinsky will also be a producer on the
limited series so I guess we know which
what side they're doing production
begins on the Fox 21 Television Studios
FX production in February that's in
forever with the third season premiering
Sunday September 27th 2020 at 10:00 p.m.
and have a child
News Now okay see you in a year no I
honestly I hate when people report on
things like so early on it's like get me
excited no I know but then like the time
flies but there is such thing as like
too much momentum like you can release
something like the news about something
so far in advance like by the time it
rolls around like people are either
annoyed or they just don't care like I
feel like four or five months is like
the perfect amount of lean time for a TV
show yeah but you know what I'm glad to
know this like I'm excited to get
excited maybe I'll watch some
documentaries about it and like then
have more information going into it so I
could be like hey yeah that's not what
happened
Monica Lewinsky is like an interesting
category of celebrity where she's like
famous for like this awful thing but she
like gets to go and watch up inside
because of it so like but does she like
have a job I don't know I don't know I
think she does TED Talks do they pay i I
do think they pay I don't know if hers
are like you know breaking YouTube no I
think that they would be like what does
she do flake breath she talks about like
internet bullying what does she do for
it
right did she have like a settlement or
anything from bill I don't know who's
gonna play Bill and Hillary I don't know
artillery are they gonna be in it
honestly they should have kate mckinnon
play hillary like she's so good at it
yeah but she's good at in like a
satirical way i believe maybe she could
take it in a serious direction yeah I'm
down yeah and then like honestly the guy
who played George Bush should play Bill
Clinton like he's just perfect up for
being president
you mean Sam Rockwell Alicia [ __ ]
longlegs this has been yeah yeah Sam
Rockwell that would be really like a
great casting yeah he should just play
every president yeah no he didn't he
also play um Dick Cheney no that was
actually memo but he was in the movie
yeah that's nice oh yeah as Bush yeah
but it was also a movie about Bush no W
Josh Berlin oh well so many bushes so
much Bush I gotta go to the wax the wax
what are you got a European wax Center
it just makes a joke less funny Margo
okay next up some fun news Cameron Diaz
has resurfaced in a rare interview quote
I don't miss performing I am living my
life Cameron Diaz hasn't been on screen
since 2014 Annie and in a new interview
about her life and happiness now the
retired actress said her time out of the
spotlight is entirely intentional quote
I started experiencing Fame when I was
22 so 25 years ago
a long time Diaz who turns 47 this month
told in style in a profile published
online on Tuesday the way I look at it
is I've given more than half of my life
to the public I feel it's okay for me to
take time to myself now to reorganize
and choose how I want to come back into
the world if I decide to I don't miss
performing the four-time Golden Globe
nominee says she has some things brewing
but she's not ready to offer up
specifics secret project ooh we love a
secret project quote it's fun to just
not have anybody know what I'm up to
because my time is online
I'm not sailing on any shelf I'm not
selling it on any films and because I'm
not selling anything I don't have to
give anybody anything
I'm not doing this anymore I'm living my
life you know this is what happens when
you have a good agent and you just
choose good movies because homegirl made
80 million dollars with Shrek and she
don't have to work anymore and you know
what goals but there's tons of animated
movies that have done super well and you
can make the argument that's they don't
have to work any like I'm sure Ellen
DeGeneres after being Dorie it doesn't
work any melon doesn't have to work
anymore and like they keep asking like
paying her so much money for one more
season like she doesn't have to work she
actually might like to work like I think
that like Cameron Diaz that her husband
like want to start a family and like not
they're a bunch of animated movies that
do really well but that don't have for
films and I'm sure Cameron Diaz had a
deal where she doesn't like every time
the movie made a dollar she did to like
one of those back-end deals yeah to a
story like super 7 large
yes but timings probably likes work like
some people just don't maybe it was like
this Shrek pack because also Mike Meyers
did that it wasn't a pact it was like
the first movie of its kind where those
people got like those types of deals and
it's like everyone who was Eddie Murphy
never worked again like if you were in
Shrek you never have to work again and
now there's your grandchildren damn so
lucky that's that's the dream do you see
that makes Randy boots what's his name
Antonio Banderas I think is that the dad
from Spy Kids yeah he also doesn't work
but Meghan Trainor's living large nice
what was a what were we oh do you see me
some Ramses yeah that's a cameo in Angry
Birds how [ __ ] cute Oh Luke Combs is
on the soundtrack like how in tune is
Angry Birds I gotta go see now like his
face is it or his voice no his voice his
voice I can't he plays like the little
one like it's just such like a weird
franchise that was like a game that like
was a billion dealt me like a theme park
good for them that is the dream it's his
a dream theme park is a dream kimmy
schmitt oh my god yeah
my wish came true yeah no grand world I
think I feel you yes I like just cuz I
literally had nothing else to do except
it bothers me it ended everyone is so
successful and it's like we just watched
them slumming and live in the side of a
boat for I guess I'm the street and I
want to see them being rich right that's
always what happened I want to see
Jackie Lynn back on top with white
talent she's so funny she's so funny
we haven't talked about Cameron Diaz
much because she doesn't work right
she's not like in the press ever and I
just love her I feel like recently I've
had a new appreciation for her I feel
like growing up she was kind of like a
Jennifer Aniston to me where I didn't
get it but after the other woman like I
turned a corner
no she it's it's something about her
like she you can consider her like a
Kate Hudson like rom-com but if you
think about her catalog of movies like
she more often than not chose like
really excellent roles like okay the
other woman but Something About Mary
like that's just on a regular rom-com
like that's on a failure to launch
that's a real [ __ ] movie the sweetest
thing oh the best like you think of her
you just loop her into like those other
like tall skinny blonde girls who like
did a bunch of rom-coms fool's gold but
she's not like she has her own entity
she's not a Katherine Heigl she is and
he took the other woman for me to
realize that because she she's Miss
Hannigan like if you could be Miss
Hannigan and then also be like Carly the
lawyer and the other woman that you are
a talented diverse actress and Miss
Hannigan is an iconic role played by
iconic people so even though like I
guess the movie wasn't a huge success
the mask the mask dichotic who played um
Annie when uh
she was Miss Hannigan uh Carol you know
Kathy Bates played once and then who
played what happens in Vegas Charlie's
Angels Charlie's Angels bad teacher oh
my god it's the best movie of all time I
think he might I might love it more than
the other woman that's right I think
that was the first one where I was like
oh my god this movie is iconic and every
time I watch it I want to be a teacher
who played Miss Hannigan when quitman
janae Wallace was at Annie Cameron Diaz
Cameron Diaz this rewatch I move the
holiday my sister's keeper the holiday
my sister's keeper that movie was so
sad I'm shook y'all you know there's
something really like she she's like an
oversight because you kind of just loop
her into this like rom-coms stupid movie
like genre but she's not like she is
like a really [ __ ] talented and now I
know why she's a retirement home girl's
[ __ ] rich oh so then I went down this
hole a few months ago where I watched
bad teacher and I was like I just need
to watch anything with Cameron Diaz so
then I stumbled on this movie called the
gambit with them this guy who looks like
mr. Darcy but isn't him so her Hugh you
know him grin know from mercy he looks
like Pierce Morgan I always confuse the
two of them Jackman that guy Colin Firth
got it oh I love him so it was like the
dumbest movie ever can I quite enjoy it
so like even her mistakes are fun so now
I'm just happy for her like she weren't
she really Carol Burnett whatever was
Miss Honey and I got Carol now that you
know like she really worked so like did
so many movies over the course of 25
years like she's [ __ ] tired yeah and
I think she's she really is living her
best life and whatever she does next I
can't wait to see it cuz I like her
taste a great and she has such a normal
life like she's living the dream
and like she's so rich her net worth is
140 right and by the way she gets hang
out with Nicole Richie because they're
dating they're married two brothers
their sisters in law cute do you think
they ever hang out no but Richie was
like always instagramming I feel like I
would see Cameron Diaz in the background
interesante Cameron is married to Benji
and Nicole is married to Joel and their
mom is Steve their dad is Steve whatever
Oh actually yeah Wow Madden family and
so like who's richer I don't know this
is the best types of relationship but
like you don't know who's richer but
like it doesn't matter yeah nice nice
like who's that you're Nicole or Cameron
I really don't know ooh
cuz Nicole's got that inheritance money
I know but I think Cameron um because
Nicole's a split it was Sofia yeah and I
think they have another sibling yeah
definitely Cameron okay next story major
beef is brewing between Charli XCX and
the Swifties because she apparently
dissed the reputation tour basically she
didn't interview with pitchfork like
asking what it was like to like be on
this mega stage you know stadiums all
around the world sold out every night
and basically she was like yeah
like grateful for the opportunity but at
the end of the day like I kept feeling
like I was going on stage and performing
to five-year-olds which as a 25 year old
swifty I that might be the case because
I can guarantee you nobody showed up for
kart Charli XCX so maybe it was
five-year-olds like the people whose
parents had to take them but like one at
Mason I had to go home before their
curfews yeah like with the American
camber like I didn't I barely showed up
for Camila Quebec by fat ass is getting
up even earlier to go to Charli XCX so I
can hear one song that she made 10 years
ago like I'm good um but what she was
trying to say is like and just going on
those stadiums where like literally
nobody knew who I was really cemented
for me that like I much prefer to be
this like underground artist playing and
like packed tiny venues I'm like yes
Bochum by someone who could not sell a
ticket if her life depended on it saying
no I prefer making less money and being
less famous yeah sure but now the
Swifties are up in arms like a biting
the hand that feeds you and be like
we're fighting just as five-year-olds
when like Taylor's been around for 10
years so like Swifties have to be at
least 15 yeah yeah you know what I mean
like it's so stupid but just like what
what it's not the face
like I'm sure like those coveted spots
like look what it did for Shawn Mendes
like that's a coveted opportunity and
like just to take a big dump on it like
okay these are should I just have to say
like it could have told you that this
was not the right fit I couldn't be sure
we did say that you did and Taylor was
just like trying to sell our tech making
it makes that chap and I think she
really wanted to have an all-female
roster I think she had to have like pick
someone from her label like I'm sure it
was slim [ __ ] Pickens and like
Charlie Axios was literally the only
person available because like I said
she's not successful okay and apparently
their dad is not Steve Madden what I can
you that couldn't know Jackie it's 100%
I know but like I just now we need to
now I'm doubting
see Roger Combs I can't
maybe not I thought their dad really was
Steve I my three children Jack Stevie
and Goldie okay [ __ ] yeah
wonder if Goldie mat is a toaster oh my
god and the good charlotte of it all
back in their band Wow love it okay back
to trying this just makes Charli XCX
like look like regardless of like Taylor
being involved like who would ever want
to work with her now like she's just
gonna like like take a jump on
opportunities that she's given and being
like
good luck with your underground artists
vibe amazing
at what point like she said every
opportunity really like every machine
has tried so hard every awards show like
every campaign you know everything at
what point do the people like in the
conference room upstairs just say move
on like we're we're not gonna put any
more money in today that's a great like
I don't know who her label is but I
can't imagine they're making like an
amazing return on her work so that's an
interesting question at what point like
I feel as though the people working on
Meghan Trainor's label did recently make
the decision that they were gonna just
really tout her out as like a celebrity
not like a performer ya know they were
gonna pivot and I think they're doing a
good job she's just an influencer now
yeah and she was on the for and like
that's interesting that he is a
songwriter she went on summon and she
represented herself really well she I
was like now I'm like invested in her
and Juni's relationship like I'm more
like I look at her now it's like an
influencer that I follow as opposed to
being a singer because her music just
didn't do it for me or the American
people you know what I feel like
happened it's like she was climbing
climbing climbing and they were like you
know we're just gonna decide that she's
made it and we're gonna treat her like
she's fighting it yes because like you
can only get like a job I'm like a
singing show it's like you owner success
yeah so I feel like they could have done
this with Charli XCX where they put her
on the for and we're like oh I guess she
made it but I'm so glad that they didn't
know I know like Meghan Trainor as much
as I'm not like here for her as a
performer like she actually is a really
impressive songwriting background where
she like has written a bunch of hits
that people might not know about so she
is talented and even if you don't like
her songs like all about that bass
lesson number one so it was like the old
town road of its time and by the way it
was a good song it was annoying but like
that's an accomplishment to get a song
that's that popular and really
galvanizes the people and while Charli
XCX did have that I don't really
attribute the success of fancy to Charli
XCX I honestly didn't even know she was
a sheet song song yeah yeah people know
but no clap is her song and was in all
those movies we're doing would be shame
me shailene woodley both in our stars
and she was just riding that boom clap
well she was also in the fancy which
probably gave her the opportunity to
really a spoon clap and Iggy Azalea made
fancy what it was the music we know cher
Hurwitz made fancy what it what row so
true but I do feel as though like Charli
XCX
well for herself hurt song boom crap is
in every single movie like good bad she
must be my new royalties so it is what
it is
I think like she can go home you know
and be happy with herself and maybe get
a job in marketing yeah I think that
would be good for her know what should
be performing in clubs like that's ya
know great have a good time like if we
were going to a club and we heard
charlie accepts XCX was performing like
cool that's the vibe it's just so silly
because like would as a performer like
regard listen how you feel about Taylor
strip like her fan base is so big like
what do you even want a slice of that
like she like I just seem like such a
stupid thing to do business-wise yeah
even if she did feel like she hated the
tour she finally she was performing to
five-year-olds and she hated it so much
like why would you say that that's just
like bad business
yeah like justice for five-year-olds
yeah yeah I'm fine paying your bills
yeah yeah I know the best way if
five-year-olds are out your concert that
has to mean their parents are there so
you were also performing to adults yeah
like 50 year olds arguably more
embarrassing averaging out you're
performing to 25 year olds isn't that
what you want it's perfect
okay good then final story a little
business very excited sad business Oh
Sears and Kmart are closing stores 21
Sears and 5 Kmart locations are to close
in October
I hope what's at the Kmart in the city
it's like such a great staple of
downtown it's in the Nicole's no no
there's a Kmart master place no I've
been it's a perfect for the college kids
who like need stuff for their dorm it's
like really a great Kmart I really hope
it doesn't get taken down um hopefully
not more seasoned Sears and Kmart they
learned by the same conglomerate I guess
so if ya see or see I guess they're both
on my Sears with CEO any Eddie Lambert
so Sears is is truly maybe one of the
saddest chains they can't get their [ __ ]
together and I went to a Sears once what
do you assume they sell it Sears he's
right that's what I went for
it's not PC Richard no they only sell
like kitchen appliances so I can even
microwave like no need [ __ ] TV inter
son we are bright and weird after
closing thousands of stores over the
years and nearly six months after
emerging from bankruptcy the to
retailers parent company announced
Tuesday that 21 Sears and 5 Kmart stores
will close in late October we've made
the difficult but necessary
sorry decision to close 26 large-format
Sears and Kmart stores the company said
in the statement moving that Sears Auto
centers at many of the stories will
close in late August
what's an auto center I don't know maybe
they fix cars Oh a Center for auto oh
thank you according to the same in
liquidation sales are expected to begin
around August 15th booth sales and
eligible associates will be offered the
same number of weeks of severance as
offered to employees of Sears Holding
Corp you know we should do we should
take advantage of them being in a low
and by Sears and like build out a studio
and have an audience that would be cool
maybe the ex-head you want the Kmart in
the city to go out we could buy the
property totes great location it is um
this is really sad for the Sears and
Kmart employees I mean yeah and anytime
like a brick-and-mortar store goes out
it's like sad because it's like one more
step into robots
yeah that's really how I feel it's like
Jeff baisemeaux set for Jeff Bezos ya
know it's like from with every brick you
know I'm not gonna finish it I don't
think I'm gonna make it funny I
understand what you're saying it's like
okay it's a with every brick with every
retail brick getting smooth no I don't
know I understand what you're trying to
say it's like with every physical brick
put into a brick and mortar taken away
it's going to the dollar a Jeff Bezos
pocket it's like feeding a robot I
actually saw a graph like the worst and
now that's why I tried right now um
thank you and arguably you brought us
down so I really like cut our losses
I read a chart on Instagram so I don't
know if it's true it's like all the
things that Jeff ways those bezos's
wealth could do okay it's like if you'd
if he gave up all this money to like fix
the world problems like he could and
poverty in America was like a million
things like you should just do it you
okay but like or all of the top people I
could give up a corner like yeah I'm
just saying it's like it's all one
person like just do it take one for the
team you know yeah and you know what
he'll like me probably like five million
dollars in a day tomorrow like he could
give away all his money I live an
average life yeah and then like every
day I think I read somewhere he makes
like a couple million dollars a day
so he just start over yeah I just think
like it's something to think about I'm
just pitching it to Jeff like Amazon's
only gonna get bigger
yeah this Jeff Bezos on Shark Tank sure
but I don't know that he invested he's
the innovator
oh that's true you know yeah and he like
buys companies for Amazon but he doesn't
like work on them outside it's like do
you want to be a part of Amazon or scram
sure okay it was that the past five that
was the Fast Five and I do feel as
though they were very robust they were I
think it's also time for us to jump in
to do toasters differences yes there's
four cuz one was short okay thank you
Margo Margo chose that and so she knows
all your secrets cuz we keep it
anonymous do your toasters at gmail.com
before having any problems at work your
co-workers be mean to you
they won't let you finish your analogies
you email us people are now okay what
are the guy how do we bite every brick
that crumbles is another chip in a robot
yes that's good okay Ashley Dougherty
with every retail brick someone's
computer gets a click
oh yes yes that's really good thank you
guys okay so helpful first dear toasters
again do toasters at gmail.com um it's
pretty short
dear toasters so the girl I see next to
at work is driving me insane she is so
sweet and a great co-worker but I have a
major problem with it Oliver cotton
Staton mouth noises I guess right here
is um I've major problem with all of her
mouth noises she chews loudly all day
long I'm not kidding there's constantly
something in her mouth she goes in
between smacking gum crunching chips
loudly sucking on mints and hard candies
there's not a minute that goes by
without some form of loud mouth noise
not only is it disgusting but it is
extremely distracting how do I deal with
this I had made comments in the past
about having a bad case of misophonia
and she said oh my god I know can you
imagine just chewing so loudly so
clearly she does not take the head
please help okay I I struggle with this
um first of all get yourself some air
pods
second of all like for example I am
someone I feel as though I chew normally
have you guys never heard me chew
annoyingly never know but like Zack
thinks I chew so annoyingly so if this
girl does have misophonia like maybe
there's nothing wrong with the other
girl it's just like her be lost to bear
sensitive to it and in which case like
it's her [ __ ] cross to bear like she
wish she wouldn't work sitting next to
anyone
yeah so maybe just excuse
maybe like work from a little pot or
something this is where perspective is
really called into question because is
the girl being dramatic or is the girl
allowed to err like if you have truly
misophonia misophonia then it is
probably not she's not doing anything
crazy but irritating you and honestly in
which case like you're not you can't say
something to her cuz she's not doing
anything wrong like she's allowed to if
I can eat retina someone who firmly
believes in the power of snacks like for
you to take that away from her would
just be like truly unjust
I totally agree and very sad look you
today Thanks so do you
thanks we tried we tried because we felt
like we were really gonna be delivering
breaking news but we are supposed to do
everyday so we should look nice no but
like we don't always have the scoop
every day like struggle are waiting with
bated breath to hear our opinion about
the fact that Blake and Caitlyn we're
pretty much dating for months and that's
right it matters I feel as though my
wardrobe has truly been elevated in the
past few months ever since we started
working with thread up agreed and also
of my consciousness clear because it
says like a sustainable better for the
environment way to shop shop your
secondhand I just think it's something
we should talk about
I completely agree did you know that 26
billion pounds of clothes are thrown out
each year and that 95% of them could
have been recycled or reused the textile
waste problem is huge and buying and
selling second-hand clothes provides
such an easy solution that's why we love
thredUP they're the world's largest
online retail store where you can buy
and sell secondhand clothing they make
it easy to clean out and then restock
your wardrobe affordably that's the best
part it's like you can buy with thredUP
you can also sell with read up I've
always liked the idea of thrifting but I
don't have the time to dick the racks of
clothes that aren't in my size and/or
style but the read app has transformed
the 13-game you can filter by almost
anything size brands style color or even
condition you could also have searches
and favorite items that you have your
eye on so I got to thanks from Alice and
Olivia that both in the tags on it and
they were like $20 that's amazing
because tag new with new with tags what
else can you ask for that's really like
a steal no I know like I feel as though
he's stealing yeah along with your great
deals you can score while shopping at
thredUP they are amazing resource to
clean out your closet order a free
cleanup kit once fill it up with your
items and then send it back they take
care of everything else you'll earn a
little cash of credit for what sells and
then the rest is responsibly reused or
recycle it feels good for a limited time
they're offering the morning toast
listeners up to 50% off your first order
when you go to thredUP comm slash toast
that's on top of the already low prices
so
hurry up and take advantage that's th r
e d u P calm / toast
that's no a thr edu p.com / toast for
50% off select items today terms apply
fret up calm / toast so I think we've
decided that that girl is just drama
queen and just to leave her co-worker
alone she should leave her co-worker
alone because it's very likely that this
is you know something that's specific to
her and the co-worker hasn't done
anything wrong so like maybe she
shouldn't have seats but she might sit
next to someone else who's chewing
bothers her so maybe she should sit
alone I don't know so maybe we should
work from home from misophonia like
sometimes headphones don't work but
earplugs might maybe try a white noise
plugs are so rude and earplugs by the
way don't work like when Co was a baby
and you would wake up at like 5:00 in
the morning barking we got earplugs from
CVS and they just don't [ __ ] work
that's where we got our ears but like
how dare they just sell a product for
years your plugs have been sold in CBS's
all around the world and they just don't
[ __ ] work uh some people would
disagree like I know Dana uses earplugs
because um I don't know she always wore
them in college I don't really know why
and she loves him she always has a pair
of ear plugs on her [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay white noise works when I was an
intern there was this guy who like he
had huge headphones and put white noise
on and like I could hear it was so if I
can distracting and like how do you
[ __ ] even concentrate no but you're
supposed to be better like it takes away
all the noise or one of those things
that's a noise what you wear on planes
and always kill your friends what about
that it seems like there's plenty of
options for this girl or maybe asked to
move your desk and like sit somewhere
alone because you have misophonia yeah
it's a condition like HR has to make you
let you move yeah okay next one hi
ladies I've been wanting to reach out
for what seems like forever but now it
seems like the time now seems to be the
time that advice is pertinent to my
situation well we came to the right
place I have a co-worker let's call her
Jaime Jaime's 20 year old she's an
absolute darling she's still in college
with not a lot of friends and I feel
like I've taken her under my wing in the
office she's kind funny a damn good
worker and actually really beautiful
recently her and a friend of mine have
been interested in each other and
finally met face to face this is my
dilemma
Jaime is
a girl yes okay do you think it was a
boy what here's why I really can't say
it
Jamie's a girl yes Jamie has a beer none
of us I feel bad I don't know I really
want to sell blow job you read it yeah
the hair is very dark and there's a lot
of it but it's so thin it not pubie I
just need to know is like this is a
style choice on Jamie's partner no one's
told her like you need a wax I don't
think you can tell if she'd ever been
tampered with my friend let's call him
David said something to me about it he
wasn't grossed out just a little
confused as to why she doesn't do
anything about it Jamie gets Brazilian
waxes on the regular so it's not like
she's never down in the wax world I also
know for about okay okay so she's a
hairy girl she's not like making it like
this isn't you know I also know for a
fact that this isn't some sort of
greatest showmen like born with a beard
situation I want to help her so bad how
do I get her to do away with the facial
hair or do I even bother she has to know
about it right she comes from a
religious family who doesn't know she
gets Brazilians so could be why she
doesn't do anything to her face there's
no judgement for me at all I just want
to help
is this just mine hers and David's cross
to bear Oh a loving co-worker I actually
feel horrible for laughing like it's not
funny because that can be attributed to
Amelia different it can be genetic it
could be like a hormone imbalance like I
know I actually know a lot of people who
have facial hair and it's not a big deal
but there is something you could do
about it but yeah the thing is it's
really it's not a big deal most people
like do you have facial hair and they
wax especially like mustache excuse me I
was once a week yeah and if I don't it's
like thick and coarse and could be could
be mistaken for young prepubescent child
man and here's the thing about these
hair I feel like it's actually the one
thing that like you can't see like when
you're looking in a mirror like there's
not bad light hitting you like but when
you're talking to someone like that
person sees those things so you run the
risk of ruining the friendship if you
say something um maybe be like and this
is my favorite suggestion to make be
like hey like you want to go get like
I'm going to get together
what do you mean looks like you
to come I got a two-for-one special and
if she's like no I'm good then okay then
she likes it and that's honey that was
her but if she's like really I've never
gotten one before like I kind of feel
like I need one you know she might open
the door and then you could be like try
it like I think it's so everyone does it
like it's so not a big deal and that's
my favorite way to go about things like
hey I'm going to get to Turin yeah go
take a shower
or it's like our favorite thing it's
like we spray Listerine normally offered
of people around us cuz they bad breath
taking out a pack of gum with someone
who has bad breath is the most genius
thing ever
yeah but like now I wouldn't finish like
takes out her Listerine and shoots me
I'm like am I in trouble and then you
get like super self-conscious but
Tanisha is always taking out early I'm
just like I can't with bad breath taking
it out because no I would tell you I've
taken out buzzed Claudia's everything I
asked you where were we where we check
it out because someone had such bad
brun-wibaux she won yeah we write acne
yeah okay I just want to apologize for
laughing like it's actually not I know I
wasn't really mean I was just like [ __ ]
because Jamie is like a gender-neutral
name so I was like maybe I'm thinking
it's a girl I I just I really want to
apologize because it's a me too I was in
love yet the situation it's not a fight
a situation the way the girl wrote it it
was just music and like show me like
that's gonna list it allow somebody and
I think we need you a great solution
like hey two-for-one lip waxing anyone
in and then what and then if you get her
there and like she's comfortable be like
cheeks you know what you have to do take
her to a nail place because those ladies
like when I'm doing my manicure my arms
they go our mics I'm like thank you
but so if you get them close enough to
one of the manicurist thematic Harris
will just be like hey Plex because they
there it's their job and it's actually
super helpful but this might be
something that she's thought about
before but is nervous like no and her
family has ever done it she doesn't know
that it's like a very standard thing so
just it's someone to like if a stranger
was suggested it she found it oh no I
don't do that but if a friend was like
hey this is a normal thing that I do she
might inquire for more information which
is all she needs his information and
with that she can do what she well
knowledge is power
yeah it's just it's it's both things
it's like you know what it's not your
business like what Jamie wants to do
with her face but also like if your
friends like you look out for one
another
yeah and she said she took her under her
wing so maybe it's like she's like older
than her
like with that said I can I feel like I
know people who I'm pretty friendly with
her I've been friendly with in the past
who like have had this situation and
Ivan never said a thing no of course not
they say like now I'm actually turning
you know it's how your freaking business
yeah
she's gotten through life this far you
said she's beautiful yeah and also like
it David is not the one to accept her
for who she is like bi yeah totally I'm
sorry I changed my shell I respected
judge T you're perfect David you're
perfect
I change yeah knock WA next one a year
ago tear testers a year ago my boyfriend
and I secretly married at City Hall with
no witnesses other than the photographer
we hired to capture the day I'll back up
to add some context I met the love of my
life my absolute person and soul mate on
what else tinder
we were both 32 at the time and we
immediately knew that this wasn't for
everything he's dated for years with no
luck and I'd been in a relationship for
nine years married for four of them but
had been divorced for three years and
before I met my new boyfriend my
boyfriend and I had been serious from
the start and spent a lot of time with
our family and friends and everyone is
beyond supportive and thinks we're a
perfect match after only a few months of
dating people already started asking
about an engagement which we always
laughed off because we just met I
personally don't want to have another
wedding and he never wanted one to begin
with we felt we had already committed to
spending our lives together so would you
just the legal paperwork at some point
and keep it moving
then one night five months into the
relationship he said I'd marry you
tomorrow at City Hall and the
conversation continued from there for
the next few days as we planned how just
do how to do just that
we picked the day I got away cocktail
dress we hired a photographer took off
work and showed up at City Hall with a
bouquet ready to take the leap we knew
that we were meant to be and we didn't
want to any of the stress pressure or
opinions of others to mess that up
genius genius a year later it's still a
complete secret to everyone except New
Year yeah year except a few Oberer
jabbers since changers we've met at bars
and recently his HR lady now comes the
tricky part
we want to tell people the truth but how
we don't want to hurt anyone's feelings
for lying to them this past year we
don't want them to throw a huge party
and tell everyone should we just tell
people one on one do we announce it on
Instagram after telling our families and
closest friends do we get a ring and
just fake a proposal and never tell
anyone we've been married this whole
time we've no clue how to get out of
this lie I'm so proud in the love I just
want everyone to know that he's my
husband
but what on earth do I do helping the
Joe hoping the toasters can come to the
rescue as they have so many times in the
past
sincerely secretly married okay one I'm
so happy for you and this is a wonderful
problem to have
no and as someone who has been through
the wedding process like this sounds
like a [ __ ] dream one day of work -
how in the world have you been lying to
your family for a year no that's crazy
that's and I think but your family's
gonna be so happy that you got married
you did it your way and that like you
are in a good place but they're gonna be
upset that you didn't tell them for a
year so I like that's the part that you
need to figure out how you're gonna
explain also like figure it out soon
because the longer the lie goes on the
worse the reaction could be and then the
day your tongue on something happy and
celebratory like it can't be that no but
then it's like if I knew that you were
married for a full year and like we're
close and you didn't tell me it's like
we're not close you know it makes me
doubt yeah and it's like what else don't
you tell me you know and why wouldn't
you tell me you don't trust me you don't
think I would be happy for you
so maybe like every relationship is
different but I don't know I'm just like
really I would be really upset and I'm
personally I'm upset that I'm just
finding out now that you got married
yeah I would say the best of all the
things you suggested don't fake a
proposal that is the worst idea and
prolongs the lie and then you're lying
more and it's more complicated and it
will fall apart I would say tell your
close family and friends like now and
then do a post on Instagram that's cute
it's like a cute concept that like you
really just like wanted to like spend
this year whatever like you could frame
it and you have a cute narrative yeah
you could be like we got married like
privately because we didn't want to deal
like you've been through this before you
didn't want to go through it again fine
and then we kept it to ourselves for a
year just so that like we could give the
happy news that like we're in a
successful marriage yeah but tell the
family and not have to like make you
guys go through it with us you know we
were figuring it out as we went and now
it's figured out and we're happy to tell
you and don't lie anymore stop lying
like Charlie lies are not good honesty
is the best policy I feel like the one
thing I learned in school like growing
up that actually like was valuable it's
that like lying is no good like I don't
need Alex where they don't need job and
to be like in kindergarten when they
were saying like what's popular stories
right and what's right they said I was
popular they tell the truth
like totally yeah all of those signs
really we're like gold mines like never
stop asking why I mean at a certain
point like in general question things
yeah also I think about maybe once a
week how pertinent that poster is what's
popular isn't always right and what's
right is it always popular literary tape
Blake and Caitlyn like yeah the world
took Blake I'd be like I don't feel for
Caitlyn and I won't stop asking why
right never stop asking why and you
should treat them on to others
you would have them treat unto you yeah
there's only way that's the Golden Rule
yeah under the golden arches big us
police have you had one more dear
toasters no oh yeah and also we gotta go
oh we have ok the snatcher will be up
later today feel free to subscribe it's
number four in the iTunes Store it
shouldn't be that hard for you to find
it's also available on Spotify this has
been the Millennial morning show of the
morning toast we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube we're also available as a
podcast on Spotify iTunes stitcher
anywhere you can find us make sure to
subscribe to us on YouTube give this
video a big ol thumbs up turn on post
notifications if you want and then also
head over to iTunes leave a review a
subscription about how amazing counted 5
star house we are thank you guys so much
have an amazing day have an amazing day
of so much to get to the snatcher right
now like I'm just gonna vomit all over
the podcast equipment mwah
you